[Musique]
bonsoir à tous après une pause de 24
heures lié évidemment à l'hommage rendu
à bernard tapie le débat politique est
reparti avec un président macron qui
aujourd'hui est à les caresser dans le
sens du poil les animalistes avec le
pouvoir algérien ulcérés par les
dernières déclarations du président
français avec demain la première grève
nationale depuis la rentrée sur le
pouvoir d'achat préoccupation majeure
des français sur ce terrain le guen
gouvernement d'ailleurs aimerait bien
défendre son bilan le bilan du
quinquennat la majorité est elle prête
précisément à mener la bataille de
l'opinion commencera-t-elle organisé
cette majorité avec une maison commune
qui accueillera ou non edouard philippe
sous son toit basse est une des
questions qu'on va vous poser bon soin
marc fesneau bonsoir merci beaucoup
d'être dans audition publique émission
politique commune à lcp et public sénat
vous êtes le ministre en charge des
relations avec le parlement dans un
instant brigitte boucher estime jourdain
vous poseront des questions avant que
vous ne soyez cuisiné par yves thréard
du figaro notre notre part très
partenaires vrai d'abord vous interrogez
marc fesneau sur un rapport qui va sans
doute qui peut sans doute provoquer un
tremblement de terre dans l'église
catholique et au delà c'est le rapport
sauvé le rapport de la commission sauvé
qui a travaillé plus de deux ans et demi
pour faire le clair sur les abus sexuels
au sein de l'église catholique qui nous
dira combien de prêtres ont été bourreau
combien de mineurs ont été victimes il
ya le chiffre serait absolument
accablant est-ce que le gouvernement va
réagir d'abord au certainement mais
d'abord la première réactions qu'on peut
avoir c'est qu' il était temps qu'une
commission puisse saisir et on verra les
résultats on a des premiers éléments de
ce que ce que va dire cette commission
notamment sur le nombre de personnes
concernées n'ont pas les victimes mais
ceux qui ont été les agresseurs
de ce que je lis comme vous dans la
presse mais on verra ce que dit le
rapport met par ailleurs je trouve qu'il
était temps qu'on fasse comme vous avez
dit le clair sur cette question parce
que il y avait ce qu'on disait puisqu'on
disait pas
dans un certain nombre de cas
malheureusement la prescription est à
l'oeuvre on peut dire malheureusement
parce qu'il ya des gens qui attendaient
peut-être que justice leur soit rendue
et qui au fond vivent avec cela depuis
10 20 30 40 50 ans
et en même temps c'est bien de faire la
lumière et la vérité sur cette affaire
là je pense que c'est un moment à la
fois difficile sans doute pour l'église
mais on en gagne toujours à faire face à
ces à ses pires excès devant le public
en se disant après c'est une partie des
choses celui des réponses seront plutôt
d'en haut niveau de l'église qu'est ce
qu'on fait désormais pour que des choses
comme ça mais la brésilienne mourir
pardon que des victimes du sentiment
pendant des années non seulement qu'on
écoutait pas leurs paroles non seulement
qu'on l'a niée mais que par ailleurs la
seule réponse qui étaient apportées
peut-être une réponse de dire on va
déplacer le feu le fautif d'endroits en
sachant qu'en fait on avait été victime
et que d'autres seraient victimes et à
la faune personne ne se saisisse
voudrais parler pas seulement aux
ministres vous parler avoue marc fesneau
je parlais ou non personnel est ce que
il faut que l'église reconnaisse sa
responsabilité
il me semble que dans un certain nombre
de cas elle a dit des choses déjà il
faut qu'elle aille au delà c'est pas à
moi de dictée par don à l'église de ce
qu'elle en pense mais déjà il me semble
qu'il faut faire c'est ce que je vous
disais à l'instant il sent qu'il faut
faire face à ses responsabilités et dire
ce qu'on était les fautes et parfois les
errements parfois les lâchetés il faut
il faudra sans doute que l'église est
une expression alors elle a eu deux
premières expressions sur le sujet je
crois qu'elle a essayé dans ce moment
difficile
d'abord pour les victimes c'est à elle
qu'il faut penser mais globalement pour
ceux qui y ont assisté qui n'ont pas agi
il faut que chacun fasse face à face à
ses récents revers à rennes sans que
l'église devra faire face à ses
responsabilités mais je trouve que ça
quelque chose d'utile un moment que la
réparation qui peut pas être de la
justice toujours puisqu'il ya dix ans
quand même être mais il faut que la
justice passe il faut là où elle peut
passer il faut que la justice passe mais
il faut que sur yon nous pour dire il
faut pas que la justice passe si elle
peut passer mais elle doit fuir des
affaires de prescription justement vous
disais c'est très important cette
commission 2018 la droite du sénat
s'était opposé à ce qu'une commission
d'enquêté parlementaire proposée par le
parti socialiste à l'époque sauf erreur
une enquête sur la pédocriminalité dans
l'église erreur occasion manquée je
pense que c'est une occasion manquée
parce qu'on en a toujours
on a toujours intéressés de faire la
lumière sur des faits récents ou plus
anciens et pour essayer d'éclairer
l'avenir et pour regarder ce qu'on était
les fautes des uns et des autres les
absences des uns et des autres il acheté
je le répète des uns et des autres je
pense que c'est une occasion manquée
parce que c'est terrible même pardon que
la droite à l'époque en l'occurrence au
sénat a esquivé mais tout le monde enfin
sur cette question là pourquoi il
faudrait donc pas vous à 40 ou 50 ans
mais je suis mise des relations avec le
parlement je dis que c'est une occasion
manquée que donc on a esquivé mais tout
le monde est ce qu'il fait depuis 40 ou
50 ans parce que ce n'est pas la
première fois ce n'est pas en payer à un
moment où le oui enfin ça n'est pas en
2018 qu'on a découvert qu'ils avaient
des questionnements et des questions sur
ces sujets là et donc c'est pas c'est
pas tout à fait nouveau donc c'est pas
seulement 18 18 le sujet c'est avant
2018 me semble-t-il mais il n'empêche
que c'est une occasion manquée on peut
le regretter à l'époque et maintenant
maintenant faudrait que parlement est ce
que c'est il sent que celle à
l'organisation même de l'église premiers
éléments deux il ya des éléments de
justice et de droit c'est la justice qui
doit répondre troisième élément
législatif on verra ce qu'on propose moi
je n'ai pas les propositions de se
sauver par danger g il décrit ce qui est
très important si j'ai bien compris ce
qu'ont été les axes qui ont été les
responsables qui ont été les fautifs
dans une temporalité assez longue avec
une gradation aussi de ce qu'ont été les
actes et de wow quel point parfois ça a
été atroce mais en tout état de cause
cette atroce mais il me semble qu'il
faut regarder d'abord ce qu'ils vont
dire est ce qu'ils vont faire leur
propre organisation après le
gouvernement prendra évidemment ses
responsabilités si où la majorité est
pas seulement la majorité parce qu'il
sent que c'est une affaire qui n'agace
largement les clivages on y reviendra si
besoin avant la fin de l'émission met
tout de suite brigitte boucher steve
jourdain sur les questions politiques et
parlementaires dont saint marc fesneau
le projet de loi visant à prolonger le
pass sanitaire sera présenté le 13
octobre en conseil des ministres le
gouvernement on souhaite qu'il puisse
s'appliquer jusqu'à ce qu'au mois de
juin donc après la présidentielle est-ce
que vous allez passer outre les
réticences du sénat sur ce calendrier
d'abord on va on va saisir le conseil
scientifique d'ailleurs il est saisi
pour regarder de quel outil on doit
disposer pour faire en sorte que nous
puissions être armé si vous me permettez
cette expression pour fait face à cette
pandémie alors c'est paradoxal parce que
c'est vrai qu'on est dans une phase est
dans une période où la montée épidémique
est dans une courbe inverse qu on est
plutôt dans une phase de stabilisation
voire de décroissance très forte on
continue à avoir des croates et un
certain nombre de départements pas sous
lé seuil d alerte qui avaient été fixés
y compris par le comte le conseil
scientifique il faut quand même se doter
donc le conseil scientifique donnera un
certain nombre d'éléments le conseil
d'état va être saisi sur le texte et
donc ils poseront les questions qui sont
posées aux conseillers scientifiques
sait de quel outil on a besoin en cas de
ressaut épidémique est ce qu on est
certains qui aura pas de reçoit
épidémique c'est la question
scientifique puis à la question
juridique qui sera posée à le conseil
d'état permettez qu'on cdc des conseils
dans les deux cas la mettais qu'on voit
ce qu'ils disent
deuxième élément il me semble il nous
semble quand même que
penser qu'on va complètement sortir de
cette phase épidémique
on a appris depuis 18 un peu plus de 18
mois désormais que cette crise sanitaire
existe que ce qui paraissait des alcanes
ni parfois s'est révélé d akena
précisément sur le contrôle
parlementaire de ce pass sanitaire c'est
à dire est-ce qu'il faut un contrôle
régulier à savoir est-ce qu'il faudra
voter pour deux trois mois la question
raciale qui est posée c'est est-ce que
c'est source de tristesse que - jambes
la présidentielle or vous répondez moi
il me semble que le sénat souhaite
effectivement que ça s'arrête
votre texte oui pardon sur ces sujets là
dans un certain nombre de cas y compris
sur la question du pass à me taire tout
le monde n'a pas pris ses
responsabilités nous nous avons pris des
notes ministérielles s attendait
répondre à votre question il me semble
que sur cette question là attention va
être dans un moment si ces deux trois
mois ça veut dire qu'on reporte au mois
de janvier février il faut qu'on ait des
mécanismes de contrôle alors le mans
attendait probablement des mécanismes de
contrôle qui soit ceux des commissions
ou autre est-ce qu'on a des clauses de
revoyure peut-être qu'il faut regarder
avec les parlementaires s'il ya des
clauses de revoyure est-ce qu'il faut
revenir tous les deux ou trois mois
devant le parlement quand de toute façon
je le répète que ce sont des des
éléments qui sont caduques en tout état
de cause au bout du processus
chronologique c'est à dire que ce soit
le 31 mars ou 30 juin de toute façon
c'est un processus caduque mais imaginez
qu'on réunit le sénat où l'assemblée
nationale parce que les mêmes qui vous
disent on veut se réunir tout le temps
quand si on leur dit le 15 avril il faut
se réunir parce qu'on a un sursaut ou un
ressaut épidémie qui vont nous dire mais
vous rendez vous crois pas qu'on tienne
réellement d'été au rendez vous oui mais
on n'est pas dans la même temporalité
pardon à mars avril vous aura pas
échappé qu'on est dans des échéances
électorales qui pose des questions il
nous a été demandé d'ailleurs et tout le
monde était d'accord pardon tout le
monde était d'accord nous a été demandé
que la session se termine fin février
donc il ça nécessiterait une session
extraordinaire c'est toujours possible
la session continue en fait marrer c'est
ce que je ne joue pas avant il est
toujours possible de faire une session
extraordinaire mais posons-nous les
questions de façon très réactive et
c'est ce qui a besoin d'un outil qui
dure six mois et qu'à six mois on est à
peu près sûr d'être tranquille ou qu'on
pense qu'à trois mois on est sûre d'être
prête toujours celle qui va rassurer
eric le disses a touché en tout cas à
nos libertés publiques ce texte
sur le pass sanitaire laurent fabius
dans le figaro dit qu'il faut pouvoir
systématiquement systématiquement le mot
est important contrôler les l'autre les
loi d'état d'urgence qu'est ce que vous
en pensez à ce que vous y êtes favorable
oui mais je répète d'ailleurs je suis
que l'an dernier au mois de décembre
nous avions proposé loin qui fixait les
cadre général ait pas un cadre
d'exception comme celui sous lequel le
régime sous lequel on vit je vous
rappelle qu'ils avaient eu un texte qui
avait été imaginé qu'ils étaient un test
qui permettait d'activer l'état
d'urgence avec des mécanismes de
contrôle et dans la majorité est
évidemment dans l'opposition nous
objectons qu'on vous il était trop tôt
qu'il fallait avoir du recul sur la
pandémie conte préféré procéder par des
textes qui tous les 3 6 mois ou 9 mois
que vous posez la question aux poumons
je pose est saisie automatique
automatique du conseil constitutionnel
sur ses lois mais bah elles ont été dans
tous les cas de toute façon sur toutes
ces lois le conseil constitutionnel a
été saisi non mais parce que de toute
façon de manière automatique mais
pourquoi d'eau de manière automatique
les belles fresques et parce que vous le
rende pour avoir une espionne forme de
parts additionnelles
chaque phase ils n'ont même pas le
premier gros le le premier nice une fois
je crois et les groupes parlementaires
d'opposition lancer une fois donc est ce
qu'il faut ce soit automatique c'est
prévu par la constitution voilà ce que
vous voulez modification
constitutionnelle
oui mais que sur cette loi là où que
surtout ils jouent sur les lois qui
touchent à l'état de
l'art dont il faut un peu plus de trois
minutes mais je veux bien il répond ah
les attentes quand même qu'on ait des
mécanismes de contrôle qui fasse en
sorte que dès lors qu'on active l'état
d'urgence on peut comment dirais-je
revenir soit devant le législateur soit
devant le parlementaire parce qu'une
fois que la loi est votée vous n'allez
pas revenir tous les quinze jours mais
ce que le dire c'est là qu'il ya quelque
chose que je comprends pas dans la
démonstration vous ne faites ou que vous
ne bossez cautionary le trophée national
il est saisi d'une loi quand elle est
votée les états d'urgence la en dix ans
en état d'urgence sanitaire quand vous
êtes sur un état d'urgence d'une autre
nature il est dans la loi il s'active et
haddad à 30 jours ou âgées plus combien
de jours le le parlement est ressaisi
pour prolonger ce
qu'il faut qu'on ait un cadre oui je
pense qu'il faut qu'on ait un cadre
plus global d'état d'urgence sanitaire
parce qu'une fois cette crise passée il
faudra qu'on se pose la question parce
qu'il n'est pas possible qu'on ait des
crises de même nature qu'on ait besoin
d'activer des outils et qu'on ait des
outils plus stable cela doive et cette
fois là évidemment devraient être
déférés devant le conseil
constitutionnel
mes appareils de manière automatique
mais pour la cour prévoir le pourquoi on
le ferait sur le sanitaire et pas sur
les mécanismes d'état d'urgence d'une
autre nature le faire sur les os et non
parce que l'état d'urgence non je crois
que vous connaissez ma le processeur il
ya déjà la loi elle a été votée elle a
été passée au conseil constitutionnel
simplement la prorogation des
dispositifs est soumise au parlement
c'est ça la bonne mécanique parce que
donc un conseil constitutionnel vous
appréciez pourrait parce que là je pense
que le contrôle du parlement pour finir
m dans répondait à laurent fabius il
fait une proposition ce matin dans le
figaro il est inquiet quand effet le
gouvernement ne soit pas totalement
bordée par un contre-pouvoir
systématiquement du conseil
constitutionnel répondez ya pour lui dit
mais vous lui dites comme tous les
textes qui ont été votées en état
d'urgence ont été déférés conseil
constitutionnel donc vous pour vous ça
suffit et sa proposition je sais pas est
ce que mines opérant
pardon non mais en effet de comprendre
j'essaie de comprendre et j'essaie de
vous aider vous dit qu'il ya des textes
qui ont été votées sur l'état d'urgence
qui sont passés au conseil
constitutionnel qui a donné son avis qui
a parfois censurer certaines
dispositions on est dans un mécanisme
normal d'accord donc pour vous
finalement vous faites
vous repoussez gentiment ou non des
propositions
envoyées
n'y parle d'une commission spécifique ça
c'est sur le texte dont on vient de
parler avant car en général sur
détection l'urgence ça qu'est ce que
vous en pensez à une commission
spécifique qui contrôla oui alors il ya
d'abord via les commissions
parlementaires permanentes je pense à la
commission des affaires sociales après
qu'une commission spécifique les
parlementaires non j'ai pas dit ça que
les parlementaires puissent trouver un
mécanisme qui permette d'avoir une
clause de revoyure régulière dans
lesquelles les ministres viennent
prendre rendez vous pour dire voilà où
on en est voilà pourquoi on poursuit
voilà pourquoi pour soi poursuit pas moi
je ne sais pas c'est pas un mécanisme
mauvais vous ne trouverez toujours sur
le chemin d'un contrôle parlementaire
j'ai aucun problème donc c'est la
logique des institutions vous
marc fesneau aujourd'hui on lève le
masque dans les écoles primaires de 47
départements à ce qui est de la même
façon peut envisager la levée du pass
sanitaire dans certains départements
alors c'est tout le paradoxe français on
l'a vu d'ailleurs l'an dernier je
mécanismes de différenciation est un
mécanisme complet parce que quand l'an
dernier nous avions décidé de mesures
plus difficile dans certains territoires
je pense aux territoires à marseille
l'otan vous souvienne en septembre ou
octobre dernier immédiatement
s'était engagé une espèce de querelle
entre marseille et paris est globalement
entre province et paris la difficulté de
faire de la différenciation mais je
pense que c'est bien la différenciation
mais en fait dans la différenciation
veut on veut on veut bien prendre quand
c'est dans le bon sens et quand c'est
difficile on dit pourquoi moi et pas le
voisin
donc peut être une question mais pour
l'instant il me semble que le pass and
it erp vous disiez tout à l'heure qu'il
ya des mesures privatives de liberté est
compris dans les lois qui ont été votées
par dont je vais vous dire ce qui a été
le plus près hâtive de liberté c'est de
ne pas pouvoir sortir au mois de mars
2020 jusqu'au moteur du
coup beaucoup de questions à vous poser
ça veut dire simplement sur cette
affaire là probablement c'est possible
mais je pense qu'on n'est pas encore
assez de phases là je rappelle pour les
uns c'est non pour l'instant sinon je
rappelle qu'on a un certain nombre de
gens qui doivent procéder à une
troisième injection pour re recouvrir
totalement leur immunité et que donc au
moment où on est dans cette phase qui
est une phase importante en plus et les
publics les plus fragiles en rabat
peut-être qu'il faut un peu de temps ce
sens mais c'est une hypothèse sur
lesquels il faut travailler on va passer
aux retraites la situation sanitaire
s'améliore le président ne semble pas
avoir fermé complètement la porte à
cette réforme est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire qu'on se sera définitivement
arbitré parce qu'on est président la
république a dit un certain nombre de
choses je crois que c'était le 12
juillet quand il avait annoncé les
mesures sur les questions sanitaires et
par ailleurs sur la perspective il avait
dit deux choses 1 n'est pas encore temps
de compte tenu de la situation sanitaire
de repartir sur des textes comme celui
c'est pour ça que j'ai dit la situation
s'attendait attendait et la deuxième
chose il avait dit en tout état de cause
je veux qu'on travaille et ce sujet là
pour faire en sorte qu'on ait voté ou
pas voter un texte deuxième élément est
ce que moi je suis mise des relations
avec le parlement on va dire les choses
le temps moyen de vote d'un temps d'un
texte n'avait compris en procédure dite
accélérée ces neuf mois donc il n'y a
plus dans des temps c'est moi une grande
réforme des retraites c'est ce que vous
nous dites il me semble qu'il faut qu'on
travaille sur les attendus d'une réforme
parce que c'est mieux qu'on soit au
clair sur un certain nombre de choses
mais le temps parlementaire idée très
restreint et donc c'est effectivement
difficile de le faire dans ce calendrier
souvent depuis 15 jours ou trois
semaines on commente ou des fuites ou
des gens bien informés comme disait
l'autre qui disent des choses à date il
n'y a pas de texte sur la réforme des
retraites
répondre à cette question ça sera pas
d'un projet doit de veiller à sa
sécurité
les pompes vers massabi mesures sur les
régimes spéciaux sur les retraites il
sera présenté cette semaine
si on est sur le plfss on ne fait pas
des choses sur les régimes spéciaux est
ce que ça relève d'une loi spécifique
réel effet c'est ça peut être
éventuellement des mesures autour des
minimums et ça permettrait au ministre
comédie de la santé des solidarités le
premier nice présente le plfss quand il
sera présenté c'est à dire mercredi mais
vous permettrez que le premier ministre
me disais donc on avance le bouclier
tarifaires mais une vision précise et le
wagon sera annoncée la semaine dernière
la mise en place de ce bouclier
tarifaire pour limiter précisément la
hausse du prix du gaz et de
l'électricité ça passe parfois par une
loi ou par un décret c'est par des
mesures budgétaires et par des décrets
donc dans le budget de la sécurité
sociale c'est en bus et des affaires
budgétaires oui d'accord et un mot
peut-être sur la réforme de la fonction
publique très vite une grande réforme de
la réforme de une réforme historique
hommes de la fonction de pub public et
la suppression de l'ena cette réforme
vous l'avez fait passer par ordonnance
vous êtes le ministre des relations avec
le parlement est ce qu elle pas un
mépris du parlement ici oui je vous
rappelle que la sécurité sociale a été
créée par voie d'ordonnancé l'ordonance
sur la justice des mineurs ça s'appelait
une ordonnance je veux dire nous ne
croyons pas qu'à chaque fois qu'on
procède à des ordonnances c'est un homme
et de démocratie d'ailleurs mon frère
marc vous voulez vous est peut-être
suivi ce qui s'est passé au sénat le
sénat avait décidé de se saisir de la
question de vouloir en débatte mercredi
mercredi et puis je crois qu'ils ont un
sujet c'est qu'ils ne sont pas tout à
fait d'accord sur les attendus du texte
qu'elle mais ils sont tellement cons il
s'organise entre vins très fort moi je
pense que il faut avoir recours aux
ordonnances dans deux situations et
c'est ce qu'on a fait d'ailleurs quand
vous regardez c'est un des situations
d'urgence qui nécessite d'aller très
vite vous pensez bien que quand il a
fallu mettre les mesures sanitaires on
avait besoin d'avoir des ajustements
tellement technique il fallait que ça
soit pas voir d'ordonnancé et deux camps
c'est quand c'est même si on n'est pas
dans l'urgence quand c'est des éléments
extrêmement technique que ça passe par
grenon ça n'empêche pas d'ailleurs
ça n'empêche pas par ailleurs ce qu'on a
fait y compris sur la justice des
mineurs donc la réforme de l'ordonnancé
de 45 que dans certains cas le
gouvernement fasse le choix d'avoir un
débat au parlement et il sera testé
il ya un débat au sénat donc on va
regarder comment ils déroulent au sénat
mais
le critère c'est ce que je vous dis
comme critère le critère de décision
maintenant c'est un peu le cadre et
permettez-moi de le dire il faut qu'on
ait cette réforme sur le mayorat un
débat au sénat il va s'organiser la
cette semaine et donc à partir de là
c'est intéressant d'avoir l'avis du
sénat remet une fois qu'on a une réforme
de cette nature là c'est bien qu'on
puisse en débattre c'est bien aussi
qu'on puisse avancer donc c'est pas
exclu non on est au milieu du gué je dis
qu'on n'est pas au milieu du gué il ya
un premier débat au sénat oui mais vous
me permettrez de dire que quand vous
commencerez
dire pardon que non parce qu'on dit sert
de tout le monde veut faire des textes
et tout le monde veut faire des tas de
choses mais cette semaine de temps
parlementaire d'ici la fin la fin
février
trois semaines au sénat donc on peut
toujours dire qu'on va tout faire et je
peux vous dire ce soir parce que ce
serait bien de dire qu'on va tout faire
mais pardon j'ai un peu gardien des
horloges et faire en sorte que les
textes qui sont en cours soit votée elle
est très vite de questions mais très
intéressant très concernant une
proposition de loi les républicains va
proposer jeudi d'un nouveau
individualisé l'allocation adulte
handicapé beaucoup de français ne
comprennent pas pourquoi vous refuser
cette individualisation est-ce que tout
simplement c'est parce que ça vient de
l'opposition non non vraiment pas du
tout sur un sujet comme celui là
simplement on est un peu dans des choses
comme mode c'est à dire que il me semble
que quand on est sur des textes de cette
nature là qui ont des conséquences là on
est sur l'allocation adulte handicapé
d'ailleurs il ya le texte a été voté en
commission et il a été amendée vous
permettrait que quand c'est un texte y
compris de l'opposition puisse y avoir
des amendements du parlement enfin
obligé de tout prendre non plus et 2 ça
pose d'autres questions qui sont à
partir du moment où on le fait sur
l'allocation adulte handicapé ça pose le
problème du coup la conjugale isation
tout court est ce qu'on a le droit de
poser ces questions-là sans que ce soit
une offense faite à l'opposition peut
pas le faire sans que sa filiale
question qui est posée sur 7 et sur la
en tout cas on va
sur le principe même de la conjugalité à
sion vous êtes d'accord
moi la danse conte vocalisation ben
justement jeu il me semble que ça mérite
à des congés égalisation le système
français basée plutôt basée sur la
conjugue à lisa sion si vous touchez à
la conjuguer la nation moment tout en
question ça pose une question de si vous
le faites pour ça immédiatement combien
même n'est pas de sujets juridiques ça
pose la question de pourquoi vous le
faites pas pour le reste est donc ça
pose la question du modèle et il me
semble que ça c'est un débat qui
pourrait être un débat intéressant dans
le moment présidentielle que nous allons
traverser c'est conjugale isation des
conjugale isation quel est le modèle de
la prestation sociale
sur quel modèle ans base pour la
construire voilà autre question
l'assemblée nationale a voté l'article
pour une fin de vie libre et choisit
article ou un d'une proposition de loi
du député olivier falorni mais l'examen
du texte n'a pas pu aller à son terme
vous refusez de l'inscrire à l'ordre du
jour est-ce que tout simplement le
gouvernement fait de l'obstruction
gouvernement c'est pas l'instruction je
vous rappelle que sur ce texte qui a
fait l'objet traction c'est les 1000 ou
1500 abonnements de l'opposition et
l'air enfin la version pal eu la charge
de la preuve pardon deuxième élément il
me semble que ce
cd sujet tres tres très sensible et très
puissant vraiment c'est des sujets qui
dormait l'article chicago terre dans des
voix de la majorité 1 et on n'est pas
dans l'âme et quatre vingts excusez moi
c'est des sujets plus sérieux que savoir
s'il ya deux majorités ou pas c'est des
sujets qui mêlent et 36 ans mais pardon
c'est du sujet sans doute qu'ils
méritent du temps la difficulté de
certains fignon elle va plus vite que
vos ou alors un peu vous mérite du temps
vous prenez plus de temps maintenant
parlement non mais l'opinion des seize
noms mais je pense que l'opinion dit
quelque chose dans le temps sous le
vocable de mourir dans la dignité tout
le monde ne met pas la même chose pour
les uns c'est les soins palliatifs pour
les autres c'est l'aide à mourir pour
les troisièmes c'est donc sous ce
vocable qui paraît simpliste que je sais
qu'on est dans un monde où on aime bien
les choses douces et noir et blanc c'est
pas c'est plus compliqué que ça cette
affaire qu'ils faillent avancer sur ce
sujet c'est certain est-ce qu'on a du
temps parlementaire pour le faire je
vous expliquer quelque chose il ya
exactement cinq minutes la difficulté
c'est que dans une niche c'est compliqué
et en particulier quand vous avez une
partie mais après tout c'est leur droit
aussi c'est une initiation vous avez une
partie des parlementaires qui décide de
faire de l'obstruction parce qu'ils ne
veulent pas de ce texte pardon pas moi
qui vais venir leur dire ils font de
l'obstruction j'en prendrai que tu en
prends acte c'est pour ça que le texte
n'a pas été votée si on essayait me
semble-t-il d'avancé sur le sujet sans
se dire
il faut absolument qu'il soit voté avant
le 28 février et qu'on essaie d'avancer
de façon un peu apaisées sur un sujet
qui est puissant qui touchent chacune et
chacun d'entre nous parce que tout le
monde a traversé ces sujets là je pense
que c'est ça vous aviez initialement
gravier vigueur pour le faire oui mais
saignée par dont c'était pas dans le
programme du président mais ça doit
l'être dans le programme d'appui ça
n'était pas dans le poème du président
la république la question brefs délais
dans le programme de 2022 en tout cas ça
doit être dans le débat je pense que
c'est une question sur lequel il faudra
qu'on ait une expression oui bien sûr
merci beaucoup avait bouché merci steve
jourdain dans un instant extraire nous
rejoint mais d'abord un tour du côté du
figaro lac bonsoir vincent roux non sans
avouer
[Musique]
qu'elle est le fait d' actualiser qui a
retenu l'attention sahin des faits
d'actualité qui a retenu l'attention des
lecteurs et bien la visite des valeurs
macron cet après midi dans un refuge
pour chiens et chats rats gray en
haute-saône alors le président a noté le
succès à de la cause animale auprès de
l'opinion en parallèle on notera la
montée d'un courant sur lequel s'est
penché d'ailleurs un confrère paul
suffit du figaro c'est le courant
antispécistes marc raynaud est ce que
vous approuvez la montée de ce courant
bien est ce que ça vous fait peur ça me
fait peur je veux dire les choses
traînent pas moins c'est clair oui parce
que les questions parfois il ya des
choses simples parfois accepter par dont
il est parfois des choses complexes et
des décisions complexes pourquoi ça me
fait peur parce que je pense que c'est
une confusion des genres des choses que
nous nous attachions compte tenu de ce
qu'est notre place dans l'écosystème
général terriens si on peut dire les
choses à avoir des comportements et des
des devoirs vis-à-vis des animaux c'est
une chose
que l'on donne les mêmes droits au fond
parce que c'est ça l'antispécisme aux
animaux qu'aux hommes ça voudrait dire
qu'il faudrait savoir quelles sont leurs
devoirs parce que sinon peut pas mettre
à égalité des situations qui ne sont pas
égales et moi je trouve que dans le
moment qu'on ait une espèce de confusion
des ex des esprits qui place sur un pied
de même égalité les êtres humains
l'humanité
et le reste du vivant on peut à la fois
se préoccuper du reste du vivant
d'ailleurs je pense que c'est une
responsabilité première des êtres
humains en particulier dans le moment
qu'on vit les questions de biodiversité
les raisons parce que nous en sommes
responsables et où pourrait par contre
nous sommes pour une grande part
comptable de la dégradation pour pas
dire pour la grande part mais pour
autant dire je mets un signe égal entre
l'humanité dans ce qu'elle est
et la vie l'eau les autres formes de vie
dans ce qu'elle est alors là pour le
coup je pense qu'à un moment de
dévoiement qui me paraît assez grave
merci beaucoup vincent vous retrouve
tout à l'heure pour une autre question
yves thréard bonsoir 107 deux
parlementaires la suisse laurence
rossignol et pierre henri dumont députée
leur viendront vous posez des questions
vous interpeller sur le déroulement des
jeux croix des parlements enfin façon
dont fonctionne le gouvernement et le
parlement mais d'abord c'est vous les
questions politiques yves thréard
bonsoir martin reiter alors vous revenez
d'avignon vous avez et bien fait là la
rentrée du parti la république en mars
le parti présidentiel
il est question de construire une maison
commune avec votre parti le modem qui
est dirigée très longtemps par françois
bayrou et la république en marche cette
maison commune c'est bien utile de la
sphère qui est ce qu'ils valent à
diriger ce qui est utile de faire je
crois effectivement c'est de
danse qui est issue au fond du paysage
de 2017 du grand bouleversement du 1017
et qu'est ce qui s'est passé en 2017
c'est que la bipolarisation éclaté la
difficulté c'est que rien ne s'est
construit d'ailleurs à la fois chez nos
opposants et nous étions à gouverner et
ça s'est construit sur la base d'un
accord entre la république en marche et
le mouvement démocrate et moi je pense
que ce qui a permis le dépassement c'est
que emmanuel macron candidat a ouvert un
espace central qui a fait que des gens
qui étaient à droite ou à gauche se sont
reconnus dans cet espace et ont accepté
de travail ans mais vous on a besoin de
faire en sorte que ces des spas centrale
se solidifie et se solidifient sur deux
pieds si je peux dire de base que sont
le mouvement démocrate et la république
en va ainsi pour dire si ça qu on verra
c'est pas moi je pense que
principalement ce n'est pas une erreur
c'est françois bayrou et vous avez vu je
ferrais vous savez richard ferrand et
françois bayrou en oeuvre beaucoup pour
faire en sorte que ce dialogue n'est
c'est que cette construction pour ce
faire parce que c'est il faut d'abord
pour que le dépassement soit possible
que l'espace central soit ceux des alors
le département j'ai vécu la période où
l'espace central était trop faible et
que donc il se faisait dicter la loi
soit sur le flanc droit soit sur marc
fesneau le dépassement il va pas
jusqu'au bout parce qu' on cherche la
droite et la gauche vous devez être et
de droite et de gauche si j'ai bien
entendu le président de la république
depuis quatre ans et on voit que
l'ancien premier ministre monsieur
philippe va bâtir une autre maison à
votre droite et il va d'ailleurs en
lancer
la mettre sur les fonts baptismaux des
dès dimanche au havre mais je trouve que
c'est ça n'est pas antagoniste et ça
n'est pas contradictoire que ce que je
viens de vous dire un espace central se
construisent et que par ailleurs un
espace à droite et la question pourrait
d'ailleurs se poser à gauche puisse se
construire pour faire en sorte que le
dépassement et par le sang parce que le
dépassement il se fait pas parler parler
la droite ou par la gauche sinon ça se
saurait depuis 50 ans et dans la vème
république c'est le déplacement par le
centre il nécessite aussi qui est une
droite et une gauche et une droite et
une gauche qui a envie de soutenir
l'action du président de la république
il a écrit un tweet donc voir loin pour
faire bien dépasser le court terme
construire la stratégie pour la france
est né le président pour permettre à la
france de réussir ça me convient dit
c'est un beau c'est très clair et mais
vous croyez pas que il est complètement
en phase avec ce que vous dites pourquoi
ya pas d le gauche à ce moment là mais
ça c'est pas à moi de parler de l'ailé
gauche parle de lettres que je connais
le mieux 'cependant parle elle de
dendale droite ou sans ça je parle de ce
que je connais mieux c'est à dire juste
centre oui et c'est bien qu'ils aient
des gens qui ce qui se perçoivent et se
vivre comme de droite et d'ailleurs je
me souviens très bien du discours de
politique générale j'étais à l'époque
président de groupe à l'assemblée
nationale le nouveau premier ministre
edouard philippe a dit je suis un homme
de droite et je l'assumé c'est bien
qu'ils aient des angles de droite et il
assume c'est bien que le centre s'assume
dans ce qu'il est encore et que la
gauche assume dans ce qu'elle est et que
par ailleurs on puisse dans le mais avec
mon côté combine t'es tout va vite faire
virer classement je trouve que c'est
très bien une chose qui me chiffonne il
ya quelques milliers sans que vous soyez
issus de la droite dans votre
gouvernement de monsieur darmanin
monsieur le maire monsieur lecornu
pourquoi il n'avait pas rejoint de
monsieur philippe sais pas pourquoi on
peut les habiter vous les invités à
venir dans la maison commune ouais mais
il ya deux choses pardon il ya la
construction partisane et je pense qu'on
a besoin de remettre de l'ordre dans le
paysage politique pas que nous
globalement on voit bien vous le voyez
tous et toutes on est dans un paysage
qui est un peu fracturée qui est un peu
lisible donc on a besoin nous pour ce
qui nous concerne après que les autres
fassent leur oeuvre si je peux dire
accord dans les deux donc ça c'est les
organisations partisanes le centre la
droite la gauche et après la maison
commune c'est ce qui se retrouvant sur
ce qu'on a fait depuis cinq ans bientôt
avec edouard philippe d'abord avec jean
castex ensuite est ce qu'on a envie de
faire dans les cinq ans qui viennent et
donc là il faut que ce dépassement il se
voit aussi par des gens qui viennent de
la droite est ce que le président de la
république s'il veut se faire réélire
doit se déclarer candidat à l'élection
possible c'est pas moi de lui donner
conseils là le avant noël ce qu'on voit
souvent alors c'est pas parce qu'on l'a
vu souvent que ça l'est toujours c'est
que c'est plutôt après noël qu'avant
noël après est votre religion à vos moi
je pense que ce qu'a dit d'ailleurs le
premier ministre est justement hier à la
clôture des universités de la république
en marche à avignon c'est je pense que
en tout cas il faut qu'on soit à
l'oeuvre au travail jusqu'au bout dès
lors que vous rentrez dans la phase
présidentielle oui d'accord mais
non là spencer que vous êtes dans la
situation de candidats
vous n'êtes plus tout à fait dans la
même situation faire nord-est jusqu'au
dernier quart d'heure ce qu'il avait dit
j'imagine qu'on le sait le plus
humainement des temps partiels ou après
demain non non mais moi je pense que le
président de la république et sortant
est ce qu'il ya une urgence à le faire
là maintenant non probablement pas c'est
bien qu'on puisse sur un certain nombre
de sujets enfin on se rappelle pardon on
fait comme si il ya six mois on n'était
pas dans une situation attendait dans
une situation de crise sanitaire très
graves inquiétudes très fortes des
français d'inquiétudes économiques et
sociales je sais que lui on a tendance à
renverser les situations et à croire
comme un fait de
jeu puis parlons justement ce thème
parlons sur un certain nombre de thèmes
on clôture des chapitres qui avaient été
ouverts pendant le quinquennat qui ont
continué à payer peut-être dans lequel
est une candidature qui va si elle se
manifeste qui va peut-être inquiété
parce qu'en ce moment elle est en train
de chamboulé les sondages c'est celle de
eric zemmour est ce que à avignon il a
beaucoup été question mais d'eric
zemmour avec des phrases un peu
d attaque un peu violentes notamment de
monsieur vers ans
est ce que c'est une bonne technique ça
d'attaqués frontales
et d'eric zemmour de la première chose
c'est qu'il n'est pas candidat et de
pardon on a le droit de choisir ses
thèmes de campagne qui sont les nôtres
et pas être en réaction j'essaie de me
l'appliqué à moi même donc en fait sur
la console sur la question la stratégie
qui a été débattue en effet ce week-end
à avignon à savoir est ce qu'on tape ce
qu'il faut taper sur exe mois pour
dénoncer mais au risque de effectivement
pas réduit ou est-ce qu'il faut plutôt
rester indifférent et laisser voir et
vous vous êtes plutôt sur la place je
suis à penser que d'abord il n'est pas
candidat et 2 que ce n'est pas monsieur
zemmour qui va dicter la vie politique
française quand bien même ils soient
candidats d'élan vous avez vu est ce que
j'ai vu ce sondage est un sondage qui va
sortir demain dans le figaro qui est
déjà visible monsieur zemmour si ce
n'est pas à lié bertrand qui saigne ifop
pour qui si ce n'est pas à lié bertrand
qui est candidat pour la droite vous
voyez qu'il arrive à des scores qui sont
proches assez proche de ce bar in le
monsieur monsieur thréard oui est ce
qu'on aurait pu avoir le même tableau
des élections de 2016 à hadath en 2016 à
date en 2011 à date en 2006 pour vous
dire j'étais en train de voir pour vous
dire que à date les sondages ne font pas
une élection par donges excusez moi je
répète un truc un peu idiot à date en
2016 vous aviez alain juppé face à
marine le pen fn amour
non mais j'aimerais dire non mais j'ai
pas net il y avait derrière meoli depuis
ce que j'essaie de vous
si vous aussi vous avez vous connaissez
comme moi la vie publique vous savez
qu'il ya parfois des phénomènes et vous
êtes en train de me mettre dans
l'hypothèse de il va être face à
emmanuel macron bon on peut ne pas
partager ce sentiment là je pense que
rien n'est stable dans le moment
convient parce que la situation est par
nature instable et la crise épidémique a
renforcé cette instabilité donc c'est
les hypothèses de septembre montrez moi
un moment où les hypothèses de septembre
ont été avérés depuis 25 ans elle
n'existe pas parce que l'on a connu jean
pierre chevènement y compris jusqu'aux
février ou fin janvier si j'ai bonne
mémoire en 2002 à 14 il a fini à 7 on a
connu d'état d'épisodes donc
que monsieur zemmour soit candidat bien
s'il en vous s'ils veulent être qu'il le
soit qu'on ait des débats politiques sur
ce qu'on veut faire du pays pendant cinq
ans très bien et parfait mais pardon une
date envie de rire mais j'ai pas envie
de résumer le débat public à l'hypothèse
d'un candidat qui n'est pas candidat je
fais des sondages qui ne sont qu une
dernière question il ya un autre sondage
paru la semaine dernière un sondage
ipsos qui montrait que si vous ajoutez
madame le pen à monsieur zemmour en
termes d'intentions de vote des
électeurs on arrive à 31% des voix
exprimées est ce que ça vous inquiète de
voir ce que certains appellent l'extrême
droite à 31% en france monsieur thréard
combien fait madame le pen au deuxième
tour de l'élection présidentielle
en 2017 là je parle du premier tour met
d'accord mais vous faites des totaux
fait les mêmes noms mais d'accord mais
fait les totaux je veux dire ce qui
m'inquiète c'est évidemment que ces
idées-là progresse parce que je pense
que alors je sais pas si elles
progressent d'ailleurs mais en tout cas
qu'elle soit aussi puissante dans le
pays parce que je trouve que cette
espèce de vague populiste qui fait que
fonda des débats caricaturaux que dès
qu'on fait dans la nuance ce qui est
plutôt la marque de fabrique de l'espace
dont je suis issue évidemment ça va pas
parce que c'est blanc ou noir puisque
vous me reprochez un peu d'une certaine
façon tout à la paire pardon je n'ai pas
n'est pas noir je n'ai pas envie d'être
dans le blanc ou noir dans ces affaires
là mais par ailleurs c'est vrai qu'il ya
des mouvements et des montées populiste
qui sont d'ailleurs pas seulement un
sujet français quand vous regardez dans
la plupart des pays d'europe et du monde
c'est des sujets qui sont très puissants
donc c'est à ça qu'il faut veiller je
pense que la responsabilité non
seulement de la majorité sortante mais
globalement de ceux qui sont vigilants
sur un certain nombre de questions et d'
équilibre dans un pays et de penser
qu'un clip qui est fracturée quand vous
voyez l'expérience qui a été vécu par
les américains est qu un pays qui est
durablement fracturée après monsieur
trump et ce qui se passe au brésil vous
n'avez pas forcément envie de rentrer
dans des logiques comme celle-là
permettait que moi je pense qu'il faut
pas y rentrer après ce n'est pas
seulement question d' extrêmement a
d'ailleurs ces questions de hyper
populisme ou pas la vérité c'est que
tous ceux qui ont fait ça ils se sont
heurtés au mur des réalités et face au
mur des réalités ça mène souvent des
katas merci beaucoup merci yves thréard
avant deux heures avant d'accueillir
pierre henry du mans et laurence
rossignol justement vous dites les
sondages les sondages pour l'instant ils
ne veulent rien dire en gros un essai
pour tous mais bien sûr puisqu'on est à
sept mois la présidentielle donc les
bons sondages emmanuel macron à date
comme vous dites c'est un mirage pour
l'instant mais tout est un mirage dans
les sondages mais c'est une réalité à
date puisque bonjour bonsoir
cc c'est une photographie à un instant
donné c'est ce que disent d'ailleurs au
même les sondeurs est-ce qu'on pourrait
ne pas voir à sept mois commenté tous
les mois les sondages
mais moi je me trouve à jamais sur le
terrain de l'espèce de thau satisfaction
ou le terrain de on a gagné on a gagné
lorsque j'ai une expérience personnelle
de ces sujets là donc ça apprend
toujours la modestie quand vous avez un
peu de temps de vol si vous me permettez
cette expression et de une élection par
nature
ça n'est jamais joué on a le plaisir
d'accueillir les jeunes joue laurence
rossignol sénatrice socialiste bonsoir
laurent soir ou d'être avec nous bonsoir
de pierre henri dumont députée lr pas de
calais bonsoir bonsoir à vous un débat
commun c'est la règle et ensuite deux
cartes blanches on commence par le débat
commun et on commence par vous laurence
rossignol
le chapitre que vous vouliez ouvrir
ensemble face à marc fesneau le
parlement est il respecté
allez-y vous avez la parole on va
d'abord peut-être j'ai comme j'ai écouté
le débat précédemment je voulais vous
rassurer monsieur le ministre si vous
vous décidez de convoquer le parlement
au mois d'avril au mois de mars pour
proroger de passes annie terre si c'est
nécessaire nous répondrons présent comme
nous avons répondu présent à chacune des
sessions extraordinaires que le
gouvernement a convoqué donc en ce sens
je renforce ce qui était déjà par
d'autres collègues qui n'est pas
raisonnable de demander au parlement de
voter aujourd'hui une prorogation du
passani terre jusqu'en juin prochain je
crois que c'est votre projet nous serons
là en février mars ou avril pour le
voter ensuite ma question effectivement
elle va être assez concrète je vais
prendre
un exemple nous savons en france que
l'accès l'ibg n'est pas garanti pour
toutes les femmes pour différentes
raisons sur lequel on peut revenir et
l'assemblée nationale a voté une
proposition de loi et puis ensuite le
sénat examiner ce texte est plus le
texte est revenu à l'assemblée nationale
il se trouve que par un miraculeux
hazard est un bon concours de
circonstances la majorité et leur a fait
un peu de d'obstruction parlementaire
sur ce texte mais nous avons bien senti
qu au delà de la l'obstruction
parlementaire de la majorité de la
minorité à l'ère du de l'assemblée sur
laquelle le gouvernement peut
régulièrement passer par beaucoup de
moyens de procédure le gouvernement n'a
pas voulu suivre l'assemblée nationale
sur ce texte pourquoi alors que vous
êtes ministre des relations avec le
parlement ne garantissent et vous pas
que l'initiative parlementaire de votre
propre majorité puisse déboucher
pourquoi sur un sujet aussi important
que celui de l'ibg le gouvernement
bloque
je vous réponds très précisément d'abord
on bloque pas les initiatives
parlementaires dans la session qui s'est
ouverte la et jusqu'au mois de février
environ jusqu'au mois de février
90% des textes qui seront débattus sont
des textes d'initiative parlementaire on
appelle des propositions de loi ppl
y compris d'ailleurs venant du sénat
puis s'il ya des textes qui viennent du
sénat qui ont été examinées
prochainement à l'assemblée nationale et
qui ne viennent pas de la majorité
présidentielle du sénat hier au sénat
c'est plutôt les l'air et le ps le
groupe auquel vous appartenez qui sont
qu'ils sont ensemble qui fuit qui
constitue une forme de majorité en tous
cas d'une opposition collective
gouvernement bon deuxième élément la
texte sur dives et g c'est une
initiative parlementaire le gouvernement
a tenu toujours depuis le début la prod
la première position c'était de dire on
va saisir le comme le comité national
d'éthique lequel a rendu son avis pour
dire deux choses pour dire pas
d'opposition en termes d'éthique je veux
pas trahir ce que vous connaissez
beaucoup mieux point ces sujets est le
deuxième sujet il a dit d'abord
s'attacher à faire en sorte que à 12
semaines les faces les fans puissent y
avoir accès au fond c'est ça la réponse
du gouvernement que les parlementaires
se saisissent de textes très bien le
gouvernement aldo a le droit aussi
d'avoir
l'opinion l'opinion sait qu on en a
rabattu pourquoi on est dans cette
situation là et vous avez raison c'est
autant de fois vous l'avez pas dit comme
ça mais je sais que vous pensez ça et
vous avez raison c'est au sens de
situations individuelles et de drames
personnels c'est beaucoup d donc la
plupart des cas parce que les femmes
n'ont pas accès à l'ivg et pourquoi
parce que manque de gynéco structures
qui ont disparu et ce n'est pas sous ce
quinquennat l'a particulièrement que
c'est arrivé et donc on a un besoin
d'abord parce que quand bien même on
passe de 12 à 14 c'est de renforcer les
structures pour qu'aucune jeune femme
qui soit dans la situation
d'avoir à recourir à liv et gêne puisse
y échapper quand vous êtes dans un
département comme le mien et que c'est
moins d'une dizaine de gynéco ou appelez
oui pardon vous avez raison
évidemment vous avez beaucoup moins
accès que quand vous êtes dans d'autres
territoires ya inégalité territoriale
inégalités sociales très fortes mais que
vous connaissez mieux que moi même c'est
à ça qu'il faut s'attacher et donc c'est
vrai que pour le coup là c'est une une
forme mais après tout mangé du mal
parler d'obstruction parce que je ne
sers ipa l'obstruction pour tout vous
dire je n'ai pas la bonne et la mauvaise
option de l'obstruction
ça fait partie des techniques
parlementaires c'est pas très nouveau
c'est ce qui s'est passé sur la ppl dans
la deuxième itération si je peux dire à
l'assemblée nationale il appartient au
groupe parlementaire pardon de se saisir
des questions et de faire en sorte que
parce que par ailleurs il ya d'autres
textes y en a sur l'adoption il y en a
d'autres qui vont venir sur un certain
nombre de sujets et qui que le
gouvernement
ait même pas du tout non non je suis pas
convaincu parce que d'abord j'ai déjà
mesuré la détermination du gouvernement
lorsqu'il a été décidé qu'un texte
devait être adoptée procédure d'urgence
procédure accélérée vote éventuellement
recours vote bloqué le gouvernement
dispose de tout un tas de moyens pour
faire adopter les textes et je vous ai
rarement vu renoncé quand vous été
déterminé en revanche l'as que j'ai
mesuré c'est l'absence de détermination
du gouvernement parce que vous nous
dites en fait qui compte c'est que les
femmes avant douze semaines puissent
accéder à liv et g mais vous avez vous
avez fait quoi pour sarlat depuis ces
derniers mois pour que les femmes avant
douze semaines puissent accéder à
diverger
rien non plus donc c'est un faux
prétexte pour nous c'est un faux
prétexte en fait il y à un blocage
politique
sur la question de l'allongement des
délais dit vg c'est un blocage politique
qui est un blocage qui s'exerce de du
premier ministre et du président de la
république contre votre propre majorité
parlementaire et au delà des sujets dits
vg dont on pourrait discuter longuement
ce que je trouve intéressant c'est le
moment où un gouvernement s'oppose à sa
majorité parlementaire le moment où il
ya un désaccord entre le gouvernement et
la majorité parlementaire alors quand le
désaccord vient de la majorité
parlementaire le gouvernement a beaucoup
de moyens de faire céder la majorité
parlementaire et c'est comme ça que ça
se passe en général tente mais quand la
majorité parlementaire veut faire
adopter un texte en fin de contrat il ne
peut pas le faire sans l'accord du
gouvernement c'est toutes nos
institutions et tous le régime dans
lequel nous sommes qui n'est pas un
véritable régime parlementaire et que
votre gouvernement a l'air certain point
de vue adopté et fait prospérer dans sa
dimension terriblement présidentielle
est peu respectueuse du parlement pardon
madame au chien je veux pas être
désagréable mais d'abord faut jamais
oublier c'est toujours intéressant quand
on est dans l'opposition de demander aux
autres de faire ce qu'on n'a pas fait
soi même y compris d'ailleurs dans des
fonctions vous avez exercé comme
ministre ou sortir d'une majorité qui
n'a pas mis en place l'allongement de
l'ibg pardon 2012 2017
deuxième élément le dernier gouvernement
qui a oeuvré contre sa propre majorité
pâle par le l'utilisation du 49 3
c'est le gouvernement vous souteniez
c'est à dire les gouvernements de
monsieur hollande parce que la dernière
fois sur les retraites ça n'était pas
contre la majorité c'était parce qu'il y
avait j'ai plus vingt trente mille un
nombre d'amendements qu'ils aient que la
temporalité donc c'est pas que je veux
bien entendre pardon je veux dire et je
vais pas me voiler choqué sur nos
gouvernements type ce que je veux vous
êtes nous vivons dans des institutions
laïques y sont des institutions
totalement défavorable à la
représentation populaire via lé
parlement et que les gouvernements
auxquels j'ai pu participer les faits
comme le fait que vous l'ayez fait vous
n'êtes absolument pas encourageant pour
l'avenir ce que j'attends moi pour 2022
2027 c'est un candidat une équipe qui va
nous dire je vais rompre avec cette
crise institutionnelle qui est provoqué
par le déséquilibre des institutions est
ce que je pourrais pendant les jeux
parce que je pense que là je salle
entière je suis en parfaite accord est
madame rosine je pense qu'on a devant
vous devant nous et devant vous un débat
qui est le sujet de l' équilibre des
pouvoirs en france parce que petit à
petit les greffes les réformes
constitutionnelles successives
l'inversion du calendrier électoral le
septennat transformer en quinquennat non
renouvelable plus d'une fois tous à
modifier puissamment les institutions
sans pour autant qu'on ait renforcé les
pouvoirs du parlement je trouve que la
réforme que nous avions posé sans doute
j'étais à l'époque président groupe mais
j'ai pas changé d'avis parce que je suis
devenu un ministre des relations avec le
parlement ce que j'essaie de ne pas me
dédoubler c'est mieux pour soi et pour
soi même je pense qu'on n'allait sans
doute pas assez loin on n'a pas pu aller
au bout de cette réforme et je pense
qu'il faut à remettre sur le sur le
la times une réforme une révision
constitutionnelle qui permet
effectivement de réviser je le dis
maintenant donnez moi la même que la
maîtrise du calendrier
la capacité d'initiative du parlement
les moyens de contrôle il faut qu'on
retravaille là dessus melloul
fondamentalement on vous disiez et vous
avez vous avez raison factuellement vous
décriviez la situation d'un régime très
présidentiel mais la vérité c'est que
l'inversion du calendrier le quinquennat
on y perd hyper présidentialiser et
joyeusement tous les partis y compris le
mien pour tout vous dire avaient voté ça
sans se rendre compte des conséquences
donc on a des questions devant nous et
ça pour le coup j'ai leur tâche
totalement cette nécessité dr henri
dumont députée elle est pardon mais il
n'y a pas besoin de changer la
constitution ou d'avoir un grand
programme présidentiel pour renforcer
les droits du parlement vous nous aviez
proposé avec la majorité en marche une
nouvelle façon de gouverner des besoins
par exemple le président de la
république qui venait s'exprimer devant
le congrès avec un droit de réponse en
dehors de la présence du président mais
en tout cas un droit de réponse au
moment du congrès soit mais la réalité
c'est que quand on prend les questions
écrites sont un moyen de contrôle de
l'action du gouvernement par les
parlementaires on a 70 75 % des
questions écrites qui n'obtiennent pas
de réponse dans les six mois alors que
normalement c'est une obligation de la
part du gouvernement je suis votre
exemple rapporteur pour avis de la
commission des affaires étrangères sur
le budget de l'immigration j'ai envoyé
mes questions aux différents ministères
en juillet je dois rendre mon avis dans
deux semaines je n'ai pas encore obtenu
une réponse des ministères comment est
ce que vous voulez que nous puissions
contrôler l'action du gouvernement nous
parlementaires ce qui est inscrit dans
la constitution
alors que vous gouvernement représentant
de ce gouvernement vous êtes un fichu de
respecter les délais qui en balance aux
garanties par la constitution et par le
droit là il ya pas besoin de changer
quoi que ce soit il ya juste besoin
d'une bonne volonté quand les
oppositions demande à l'assemblée
nationale la création d'une commission
denquête pour un sujet extrêmement
important qui a heurté les français la
question des sous marins de la rupture
du contrat qu'on avait avec l'australie
vous votre gouvernement et votre
majorité ici à l'assemblée nationale a
refusé la création de cette commission
denquête un moment donné on veut bien
tout entendre mais il ya aussi besoin si
on veut un parlement qui fonctionne qui
puisse accélérer et accéder aux besoins
des citoyens de contrôler l'action du
gouvernement que ce gouvernement il met
un peu du sien vous êtes la parole à la
défense vous êtes ministre pardon mais
de relations que le parlement et de la
participation citoyenne
la participation citoyenne monsieur
ministre ça commence aussi par respecter
le parlement mais monsieur dumont vous
trouverez toujours sur ce bout de chemin
sur ces affaires de questions critiques
après deux fois fait la même réponse on
attendait ouais non mais le taux de
réponses est exactement le niveau de
réponse d'eads et quinquennat précédent
on avoue du raid était supposé faire
mieux c'est ce que vous avez vendu en
2010 est qu'avec ou sans neige qu'on
allait vous savez dans ce cas les
meilleurs c'est la politique vous
énervez pas chier ma réponse moi je suis
ministre des relations avec le parlement
donc je suis dans l'interface que vous
décrivez à chaque fois que je suis saisi
une question écrite et vous avez raison
dans un tank de cas parfois les délais
de réponse sont beaucoup trop longs à
chaque fois je saisis le ministre
concerné pour que les délais soient
raccourcis la jauge orienté ça n'est pas
vrai sas ça ce n'est pas vrai le taux de
réponses est exclue pour faire une
deuxième élément
ya des ministères y compris dans la
période de crise sanitaire qu'on a vécu
qui ont beaucoup de questions écrites
c'est le le ministère des affaires
sociales c'est non non le ministère des
affaires sociales c'est plusieurs
millions milliers de questions et fait
déjà par ailleurs je pense qu'un certain
de la question qui pourrait se traiter
alors la question écrite donne du
formalisme et donnent du poids aux fonds
à la caisse à la réponse qui est
formalisé c'est pour ça qu'elle a besoin
d'être précise pas c'est une question
écrite elle est publiée mais donc on a
besoin de travailler pour améliorer les
process je suis absolument d'accord avec
vous sur cette question là
je sais pas si on a fait moins moins
bien que les autres je pense qu'on a
fait plutôt mieux dans un contexte en
plus ou les légumes le gouvernement et
en particulier un certain nombre de
ministères qui sont très sollicités sur
les questions écrites ont été pris et
mobilisé sur le sujet de la crise
sanitaire alors ça ne suffit pas le
l'effet de rattrapage est en cours et je
pense que c'est un élément important
parions sur le ton de l'application des
lois on est bien sûr d'un taux
d'application des lois qui sera très
satisfaisant à l'issue du canal heures
parce que c'est un élément important est
recrédibilisation vous avez raison la
participation citoyenne c'est aussi
d'abord ça n'a jamais été pour moi mais
vous le savez un mécanisme d'opposition
avec la démocratie représentative
premier élément pour que les citoyens
aient envie de serrer intéressé à la
politique c'est que y'a un bon
fonctionnement entre le parlement et
gouvernement si vous voulez me faire
dire que c'est parfait je vous dirai non
mais il ya quand même des choses et des
et des voix qui ont été améliorés je
vous donnais un deuxième exemple pardon
travail parlementaire quinquennat
nicolas sarkozy quinquennat françois les
propositions loi dans les niches
parlementaires elle était alors c'était
la version la plus hard 6 me permettez
cette expression sous le quinquennat de
nicolas sarkozy a été rejetée c'est un
débat c'est exactement ce que vous avez
fait de 2017 à 2019 après sous le
quinquennat tendance était plus
hypocrite ont renvoyé aux commissions
c'est à dire ce qu'on appelle renvoyée
aux calendes grecques c'est comme ça
c'est ça ce que ça veut dire en voyant
commission
2017 2019 effectivement ça continue sur
cette voie là et j'ai été de ceux y
compris comme président de groupe puis
comme ministre à dire il faut qu'on ait
des débats en niche parlementaire parce
que je pense que c'est utile qu'on ait
des débats par le malheureux par pardon
mais ce n'est pas vrai parce que vous
avez fait appel au vote bloqué à la
réserve de vote sur plusieurs
propositions de loi et moi j'ai une
question qui est très simple et très
clair jeudi à l'assemblée nationale les
républicains ont leur niche il y aura en
particulier une proposition de loi qui
est celle d'aurélien pradié sur à
nouveau la dea conjugale isation de la
hache est-ce que vous avez là et c'est
là vous allez on en a parlé tout à
l'heure est ce que vous allez mettre
dessus des procédures l'artificiel pour
bloquer les bars dont l aja léopard a
été examiné en commission la semaine
dernière comme vous le savez les textes
qui sort de la commission est vidé de sa
substance devait supprimer l'ensemble
des actifs excusez moi est faux si vous
acceptiez quelque chose il ya une
majorité il ya une opposition il ya des
délibérations d'ailleurs parfois et dans
la majorité dans l'eau plus en plus il
ya des voix qui sont dit c'est ce que
vous pouvez prendre votre finale est ce
que vous pouvez prendre l'engagement
ainsi de ne pas utiliser ni vote bloqué
mais je dirais verve jeudi de la
messieurs monsieur dumont nous sommes
dans la voie d'un travail parlementaire
classique pour le coup eux et par
ailleurs nous sommes dans la voie du
texte qui apparemment a été voté en
commission et qui sera délibéré jeudi
laissait faire le débat parlementaire
alors qu'il manque c'est aussi ça tu
acceptais la démocratie comme ailleurs
monsieur dumont laurence rossignol juste
le bon maintenant on sera signé par
ailleurs il faut non il faut qu'en mer
je sais que les niches parlementaires
sont le moment où on essaie d'ailleurs
parfois il ya sept huit neuf dix textes
qui sont proposés fait dix ans que
parfois il faut l'insolent texte alizée
deux choses la première c'est sur les
questions écrites je vais vous donner le
point de vue de quelqu'un qui a été dans
l'état vous avez en commun tous les deux
trouvé qui a toujours trop de
fonctionnaires partout qu'il faut
dégraisser les administrations centrales
vous avez l'un et l'autre un projet pour
que la france puisse réduire ses
dépenses publiques et en particulier
pour réduire les dépenses de la fonction
publique et bien je vous dire une chose
et a plus assez de fonctionnaires dans
les administrations centrales pour tenir
le rythme des questions écrites les
parlementaires en font beaucoup et nous
n'avons pas les ressources humaines en
face donc il faut savoir son vous des
questions écrites auxquelles répond et
on prend les fonctionnaires est on est
on recrute les fonctionnaires qui vont
avec sont pense qu'il faut dégraisser
l'administration centrale et on peut pas
répondre à temps et questions écrites
mais ça c'était une petite remarque
comme ça mais votre conversation est
intéressante parce que en fait vous êtes
en train de nous expliquer qu'on
pourrait très bien avec une des bonnes
la bonne volonté le respect du parlement
tout à fait permettre à notre régime
parlementaire de prospérer il en fait
nous parce que toutes les armes qui sont
porte que dans la constitution toutes
les armes tous les gouvernements les
utilise à chaque fois c'est pour ça que
je pense pour ma part qu'il faut changer
le régime constitutionnel si on veut
réellement que le parlement fasse autre
chose que de poser des questions écrites
mais qu'il est l'initiative
parlementaire des lois qui aboutissent
qu'il ne se voit pas opposé à chaque
fois que ça va coûter de l'argent à
l'état le fameux article 40 de la can
alors je suis d'un débat extrêmement des
âmes à monsieur du mans vous êtes
d'accord et ensuite la réponse de marc
fesneau non je pense sincèrement par
exemple cela qu'ils sont des qui sont
écrites ça déjà été rationalisées on
avait auparavant un stock infinie par
député de questions écrites aujourd'hui
c'est limité à une question par semaine
donc pas nous on a en tout cas à
l'assemblée c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne sous sénart c'est ainsi que
la majorité en marche a voulu
rationaliser le travail et donc du coup
il est possible de répondre à ces
questions qui sont extrêmement important
parce que vous l'avez dit c'est
mystérieux journée les droits du
parlement quand même pas des limites et
end une question par des commensaux
comment l'art et la réalité la réalité
c'est qu il y avait très peu de
personnes qui a été menée déjà ce niveau
de questions écrites et et que une par
semaine c'est largement la sur l'a4
constitutionnel laurence rossignol des
de toute façon on l'est contraignant et
on n'arrivera pas à équilibrer les
pouvoirs jeu dans ce cadre je pense
qu'il faut admettre que nous ayons un
régime qui est un régime présidentiel
mais que à côté se veut pas dire qu'on a
bafoué sans cesse et droits du parlement
qui a en effet un cadre constitutionnel
qui existe mais que le droit du
parlement n'ont pas forcément être tout
le temps être foulés aux pieds et que
c'est aussi une démarche de bonne
volonté et en particulier je le répète
de la part de ce gouvernement aux
d'emmanuel macron qui avaient dit qu'ils
allaient révolutionner la façon de faire
de la politique en fait il fait pire que
ses prédécesseurs alors exercice 2 avait
deux minutes pour répondre à ces
questions d'abord même aussi là j'ai
trop de respect pour vous pour que vous
ne fassiez pas ma propre pensée je ne
sais pas vous avez lu entendu que
j'étais pour faire la chasse au nombre
de fonctionnaires et à la dépense
publique jeu je ne crois pas que je
crois que c'est tout à fait délier de la
question des questions écrites je
n'étais pas vraiment personnel monsieur
devenir son ailier de mercenaires face
mais vous appartenez à un courant
politique pour qui la question de la
réduction de dépenses publiques et la
question des
dépassements de l'indépendance d'un pays
c'est la question de ne pas dépendre des
autres pour se financer donc la question
de la dette n'est pas une question
subalterne parce que quand c'est les
autres qui vous finance vous êtes dans
une situation qui peut se retrouver dans
une situation on l'a vu avec d'autres
pays parce que quand on dépense des
passes sur la dette vous aurez pas le
temps de finir sur la constitution et
jeux aire sur la lys est bon si oui il
ya la question des bonnes pratiques et
on essaie de le faire pardon j'aimerais
parfois aussi qu'on puisse y compris
quand on est sur des niches qu'on ne
soit pas dans des postures et qu'on
essaie de travailler ensemble gelée
souvent défendu je continue à le
défendre communiste or on voit bien que
dans les niches est souvent un moment
pour mettre en défaut simplement le
gouvernement et faire de l'électoralisme
bon très bien essayons les uns et les
autres de faire des chemins et ça c'est
des bonnes pratiques mais en revanche
pour le coup je suis plutôt à penser que
sans une réforme institutionnelle est
donc en partie constitutionnel en partie
institutionnelle aussi mais en tout cas
aussi constitutionnel on n'y arrivera
pas les mécanismes étaient déjà puissant
de là de là comment dirais-je de la
constitution de 58 mais les allées les
amendements les modifications depuis
cinquante-huit elles ont elles ont
surpondéré cette affaire mais c'est une
question aussi pour les parlementaires
on est dans un moment où les juges sur
des choses qui sont fausses quand on
juge les parlementaires que les sites
qui font ça les juges sur le nombre
d'amendements ou le nombre de ppl qui
dépose ou le nombre de questions écrites
je trouve qu'on dévoile le travail que
vous faites pas ce que je pense que
c'est pas le lion compliquer le vôtre
oui non avec tous ces amendes ne
complique pas le nôtre mais quand vous
avez sur des textes moi je gt2 celui au
moment de la révision constitutionnelle
de 2008 à meaux à dire le droit d'un
moment il est individuelle faut pas
qu'il soit groupe et donc lui très à
l'aise sur le sujet mais quand vous avez
sauf si on est dans une manoeuvre
d'obstruction alors ça après on est dans
une manoeuvre d'obstruction à faire des
retraites mais quand vous avez parfois
4000 ou 5000 amendements sur un texte au
fond vous n'arrivez plus à me sa portée
de messages politiques je rappelle qu en
angleterre de mémoire en grande bretagne
le parlement britannique sur le
breakbeat c-32 amendement ne croyez pas
qu'ils ont eu un débat politique donc
mais c'est notre responsabilité c'est le
système
des ordonnances parce que c'est quand
même un peu le problème de votre
gouvernement 18 % seulement des
ordonnances ont été ratifiés 18% par des
ordonnances qui ont été exercées dans ce
mandat c'est les ordonnances ya la crise
qu vide donc merci beaucoup merci à tous
les deux merci laurence rossignol merci
pierrot et du mans on retourne voir
vincent rouvière alive vincent roux ce
qui est des questions sur l'algérie
c'est un gros sujet évidemment le
pouvoir algérien envisageons des mesures
de rétorsion à l'égard du de la france
et du gouvernement français après les
déclarations d' emmanuel macron face aux
jeunes a requis samedi
oui c'est en tout cas une polémique et
une crise qui est très commentée par les
internautes du figaro et par les
internautes en général
à la question
posée aux internautes du figaro la crise
diplomatique entre la france et
l'algérie vous inquiète-t-elle les
internautes du figaro ont répondu à
près de 90% que ça ne les inquiétait pas
est-ce qu'ils ont raison d'être
c'est pas la première fois qu'on a on a
une crise immeuble matic avec
les algériens évidemment le ministre des
affaires étrangères était saisie de ces
questions là mais on nous avons une
histoire manifestement qui reste
compliqué je pense que le président de
la république a elle eu raison de se
mettre qu'on me disait sur d'autres
sujets au début de notre émission de se
mettre sur la voie de la clairvoyance et
de la clarté qui est fait sur le champ
historique pas la question de la
repentance en tant que tel c'est la
question de qu'est ce qu'on a fait
qu'est ce qui s'est passé comment on
peut éclairer l'avenir parce que l'idée
c'est quand même qu'on arrive à avoir
une relation plus apaisé on n'y est pas
encore manifestement qu'est ce qu'on a
fait mais il est allé un peu au delà il
a porté un jugement la pression pour
qu'ils sont pour la conversation c'est
du propos qui sont rapportés du gauche
enroulée démentez mettre sur la route
n'était mort yale martichoux quand vous
n'êtes pas dans une réunion quand on
rapporte des propos non je n'étais pas
dans une réunion de cette réunion là
pardon quand rapport des propos j'ai
appris d'expérience que je ne commente
pas des propos qui sont rapportés voilà
aussi simple que ça après par ailleurs
il ya un élément diplomatique a été
évoquée je pense pas que ce soit
inquiétant mais il faut toujours essayer
on a une histoire qui est compliqué mais
il est en même temps une histoire très
lié avec l'algérie donc il faut à la
fois ne pas s'en inquiéter et en même
temps il faut veiller à ce que nous
ayons des relations des relations avec
un pays qui est un pays voisin avec
lequel nous avons une histoire très très
puissante oui vous voulez dire à mon
sens ouvrir un chapitre pour dire que je
regrette que le ministre des affaires
étrangères a apporté au parlement une de
mes questions un soutien aussi puissant
au gouvernement algérien quand je
l'interrogé sur la répression en algérie
tout ça pour en arriver aujourd'hui à se
rendre compte que des relations
n'étaient pas si bonne vincent roux vous
avez une question encore à poser au
ministre oui c'est sur la question des
visas les on voit bien qu'il ya une
demande de fermeté qu'il émane souvent
des internautes jusqu'où le gouvernement
est
effectivement le gouvernement est prêt à
baisser drastiquement le nombre des
leaders hors normes notamment mais c'est
ce qu'il fait pas pour une raison de
fermeté pour une invasion de réciprocité
vous pouvez pas à la fois dire il ya des
visas et en même temps quand vous êtes
dans des mesures de redressement pagne
mans à la frontière le retour dans le
pays d'origine vous retrouver dans la
situation où les pays d'accueil où les
pays d'origine plutôt d'ailleurs refuse
le retour parce que là on a quelque
chose qui est une île râle et donc
cesser c'est ce sur quoi nous avons un
débat avec l'algérie et pas qu'avec
l'algérie d'ailleurs parce que si tu ya
ceux qui disent c'est assez facile et
commode mais cela n'est possible dehors
de de remettre quelqu'un dans son pays
qu'avec l'accord du pays et donc c'est
là où il faut trouver à la fois des
voies du dialogue et puis la voix de
dire un moment il faut de la réciprocité
dans un rapport entre deux partenaires
il faut de la réciprocité l'émission est
terminée merci beaucoup marc fesneau
d'avoir été avec le ruban d'honneur dans
audition publique merci nord suivis on
se retrouve bien sûr la semaine
prochaine à 19h30 pour un prochain
numéro d'auditions publiques bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]